how's everybody doing
great man how are you
doing very good you know there's a
there's an opening salvo in this movie
the first text you see on screen
that basically says you know even though
the events might be fictionalized these
people were real
why is that important especially in the
context of this being a western
dude it's real it's important because
there's a whole history here that for
the first time not the first time but
for
a significant amount of time has been
erased from people's consciousness you
know what i'm saying
and these characters in some version
have appeared in different bits of genre
but never been appeared uh a present
represented properly in a film and so
that's why that's really really
important this is not just a piece of
entertainment it is actually a little
bit of a history lesson
and watching it is like you get that too
and you also get the joy
i feel
of just everyone being there together
performing together getting to work
together regina was it kind of like a
rallying cry that you all had or a
mantra that you all had when you were um
putting this work together
i wouldn't say a rallying cry but um it
was
we all believed in in what james had
had presented to us if you will
i think for most of us i know for myself
so much about these uh
people that we were playing
i i didn't know i i didn't i had only
heard rufus buck's
name before and bass reeves and cherokee
bill but everyone stage coach mary but
all the other uh
people that we were playing i've never
heard of before so i think we just all
believed in the importance
of um
of of the telling of the story and
bringing james vision to life
and
we
also were in the middle of a pandemic
and so something that was trying to as
as
that thing was pulling the world apart
and we were losing lives we found um
something
amongst ourselves that um we're better
for it on this end of it not not to make
light of of of
you know
kovic because it's kicked everyone
but
still
it i think we were um
we got closer in a way that you know
might not have happened
yeah
sounds like a
like a project that
not only had a lot of love behind it was
a life-changing event for everyone
involved
yeah definitely
there's also the matter when you're
watching of just how fun it is to see
everybody doing all the western stuff
all the riding and the shooting and the
fighting regina that fight scene
is
wild i love it is that is that like all
you how much training is going on there
what's going on
well i think luckily zazie and i both
for from projects that we had before we
had a
little bit of uh
leftovers going on which thank goodness
we did because we didn't have that
amount of time that you normally would
have to prep for a fight scene that long
uh and we just leaned on each other
leaned on our stunt doubles you know
that
um allowed us to find
the space to
um to go you know a lot of that is dazzy
and i and and trusting each other and
being safe and and trying to uh make
sure that um we
uh leave that scene or leave those two
days of shooting um with as
minimal uh amount of injuries is
possible
that's awesome well i gotta say guys i
loved watching the movie and i'm gonna
be watching it again and again
congratulations on this good to see you
both
you